just dominate white's rook there next to  the white king that rook is almost  trapped 15 seconds okay and the rook  takes a step backwards attacking the  pawn on d5  okay so  almost hopeless for gary but still  fighting still alive okay under five  seconds though for him wesley so moving  in for the kill can he take that pawn  safely  oh i think he did have to take that pawn  okay because now it looks awful that  white king i know no safe squares to go  on the third row all black needs to do  is deliver a check and it's game over it  will be checkmate how does white escape  from this white's king is powerless the  black bishop now can just move and white  is doomed yeah even houdini cannot  escape from this one i mean look at it  there you go black rooks are about to  give some checks black's bishop can give  a check to the king as well there we go  and anish giri he's about to get  checkmated  there we go a result  over a la sierra foreign